welcome to another dr sadler's honest
review this is a series in which i
review books
that have to do with philosophy
particularly in a practical sense
so it extends into the the realm of
self-help
and leadership and all sorts of other
practical applications of philosophy
one main area is also what we can call
philosophies
as ways of life and the book that i have
to review this time
solidly fits into it it is
an scar allen's very recent book
cynicism which is from mit press it's
part of this essential
knowledge series and it's it's a
just 2020 so very very recent it's
quite good as you're going to see in the
review
and it's a nice little
copy i'm going to say a a little bit
about how i encountered the book because
you might say well this is a little bit
outside of the
the kind of books that i'm usually
reviewing so i'm currently
teaching a class on philosophy
as a way of life or philosophies as
ways of life that is called philosophy
mindfulness in life
for one of the places that i teach
that's milwaukee institute of art and
design so it's really quite cool i'm
introducing
philosophical schools concepts practices
to artists and designers who turn out to
be very interested in philosophy
and then they apply it to their life and
see how things pan out
so originally i got a hold of a copy of
this book from
our local library uh which is you know
quite well equipped in order to do a
little bit of you know background
work and and see what the latest
scholarship and research
had to say and i was struck by
just how how well this book was written
and how it suited the the kind of stuff
that i'm doing
in these book reviews so we're going to
jump right into it
but i wanted to say a little bit about
that before we
we got into the style structure summary
i like to begin the main body of these
reviews by talking about the
three s's so i give some sort of summary
of the work i talk about the style
both you could say in terms of the
writing but also
in terms of its layout and then we talk
about the structure
of the work as well and
if i'm going to summarize this i would
say that
and i'm going to avoid any sort of value
judgments at this point because i want
to get into them a little bit later
what what alan is doing is providing
a overview of
ways of understanding cynicism in
antiquity
and we can call that capital c cynicism
into the middle ages modernity
the enlightenment and then our own time
period you know late
modernity or some people might say
post-modernity whatever you want to call
it
and in the process cynicism goes from
being an
actual movement he's not really thinking
of it as a school
into being a whole set of tropes that
one can adopt
and v there's also this view of
lowercase c cynicism as essentially
a a problem of
modernity as as well and so the book is
is spanning that you know and it's it's
really doing a
again i'm going to try to avoid too much
value language at the start
but it's doing quite a a good job you
know 200
pages of the main body of the text
before we get to the other
parts of it and it's you know it's a
little book you know it's it's
um this is actually quite a short
essay and there's a lot packed into it
not an essay
a set of essays that are all connected
together
and they proceed in in order so now i
will actually get into some of the
the value stuff this book
is doing something quite well
which is without compromising
on academic rigor and
you know bringing to bear the sort of
let's call them
techniques and ways of organization
typical of academic writing at its best
not not bad academic writing but really
good academic writing
it's also oriented towards a
a much more general popular audience of
literate people who want to know about
cynicism i think you could like
put this in the hands of a high schooler
and say here you go you want to learn
about this this sort of thing this will
be you know provocative of thought for
you
and that's actually you know quite good
but i'll reserve some of this for
when i get to the good points of the
work stuff so let's talk about the
the style uh so i mean that actually
does fit into it it is very readable
i think that you know it could be
challenging in a few points but actually
not that much for for most readers
there's a lot of really great stuff
packed in here
it is incredibly well organized i think
and it's like i said it's set out in a
more or less chronological
structure that makes an awful
lot of sense let's talk about that
structure then so
what do we have we have a prelude which
is chapter one the problem with deviance
and then we have two chapters that are
really focused on well what were the
ancient cynics about
centering mainly on the figure of
diogenes but bringing in some other
cynics as well and and authors who are
talking about this
and then we have this fourth chapter
fear the mob
antique and medieval idealizations where
uh alan is talking about how there was
this tendency
when cynicism actually became a big
going concern
in late antiquity to try to provide
sanitized versions of it right and then
things like that
in the middle ages in in christianity
there's some ambivalence there you could
say and then
we move into early modernity
um and he talks about you know for
example rob lay
and and you know montan to a certain
extent
it's called fear the mob or drain the
barrel
early modern malcontents you know how
how connected
are these to cynicism are they
in any way a revival of ancient cynicism
they may be invoking the cynics or
diogenes or are they
kind of doing their own thing there's
again a real ambivalence there
and you could say that this is part of
the process of going from uppercase c
cynicism into lowercase c cynicism
then chapter six is a really important
one unchained the sun enlightened
philosophers and libertines
again it's talking about how cynicism
is being appropriated how certain people
like jean-jacques rousseau are being as
by critics for example
identified as being a cynic
how do we make sense out of the marquis
de sade or
diderot or figures like that and then
the last two chapters are really really
interesting
stuff for especially for for me but i
think for anybody who's concerned with
contemporary culture
[Music]
chapter seven is called live the end
times the many faces of modern
cynics and the question here is
what do we make of cynicism and are
there
are there people who could self-identify
or be identified as cynics
and how how accurate or appropriate
are these these labelings and
how do we have to understand cynicism in
this extent and
and alan is making the case that this is
really you know different kinds of
things than antique cynicism
and then finally he's got this coda the
inevitability
of cynicism and i would say that
one of the key questions that the work
is concerned with
and this is where it fits into you know
philosophy of life is one that that
alan rightly identifies as a question
in scholarship recent scholarship about
cynicism or reinterpretations of
cynicism
what potential does it have in the
present
what potential does it have for us late
moderns
can we can we adopt this sort of thing
can we
take you know bits and pieces of it and
use them
as i have my own students doing in the
class
using certain practices and trying to
you know live in a
semi-cynic way or is that always going
to be
these days in late capitalism co-opted
in in certain ways so those are some
really interesting
questions um
it had the book has a really
great set of we will call them
appendices right or things that are
outside of the text
that for me make it make it a you know
very useful volume
so there's a nice glossary and i think
it could be quite useful
as you're reading this to turn to the
glossary early on so that
you can dissociate the distinct types of
cynicism
that he is talking about i'll just
mention what what
the types are so right there's ancient
cynicism idealized cynics
insider cynics which is a variant of
modern cynicism
master cynics modern cynicism
nihilism paternalistic cynicism
progressive cynicism strategic cynicism
and street cynics so you know all of
those are our different types and he
gives a paragraph about each of them
then we also have you know extensive um
notes in the back he's using end notes
i'm not a fan of endnotes but
you know they're they're good you know
and it's a small enough book that it's
easy to turn back and forth
then there's actually a great
bibliography and after the bibliography
there's a
further reading of let's see here
about eight texts that that allen thinks
are the most
important for you to read and i think
i'd you know
i'd agree with him about a lot of these
um
so you know he's he's he's opening the
door
to being able to um make more
sense out of all of this so i think
that's actually
quite good there's also a good index
i'm always unhappy when there there
isn't a good
index um to a book so
that's a selling point as well so that
gives you the style structure summary
let's talk now about some of the key
ideas
the prelude or first chapter of the work
entitled the problem with deviance
really
does a good job setting the agenda
and what's not happening here is the
usual
academic in this i will do this and this
and this and chapter one will do this
and chapter two will do this
instead he just jumps in and he says
listen we've got
you know several different kinds of
cynicism here we've got this notion in
the modern period of a cynic as a person
with a low view
of humankind there was a different kind
of cynicism
its most famous practitioner was
diogenes
then he talks about him a little bit and
looks at the differences between
modern and ancient cynicism
and he says that both of these can be
understood as
deviant each entails some kind of
departure from accepted principles
of public and individual conduct so
there is a connection there
he says that as an attitude modern
cynicism is deviant in the pathological
sense of the word it afflicts
us and he's going to you know discuss a
lot of different
types of this later on um
then he says as well that cynicism might
be
viewed in a more favorable light
to make this argument which i think he's
doing in this book it's necessary to
spend some time outlining the
contrasting philosophy
of ancient cynic deviance understood as
an
act of preference rather than a
regrettable affliction
and you know then he talks about um
he's got a section here three problems
and he's talking about how do we make
sense out of
the what the ancient cynics are doing
and its connection to to other things
and he brings up freud he brings up
other people as well
um and he says that you know one of the
the issues
that we're dealing with here is just
making sense out of well what is cynic
deviance in the first place
then he says a second major problem for
a book like this
is the gulf not only temporal but also
in temperament
that lies between ancient cynicism and
its more recent
descendant what we're experiencing a lot
of the time
and um i think he's quite right about
that
and he and he says that there's there's
a couple different
other issues you know so we have the
difficulty
of accounting for ancient cynicism by
modern intellectual means the tremendous
gulf and then he says arguably any book
about cynicism
can give a sense of its object only
through an act of
unavoidable distortion just as it can
give a sense only of what according to
recent scholars might be key
points so he he knows that there's going
to be
this is going to be a controversial work
and i think
quite frankly any any work on the cynics
basically has to be even if we're
talking about the ancient literature
right
because we don't have the books that
these ancient cynics are supposed to
have
written uh so we can you know look at
them directly and
there's a lot of other you know issues
and controversies that come up
he talks about um modern cynicism as
evasive but i think you could also say
this about
um ancient cynicism too in
certain ways one of the things he
highlights about ancient cynicism
is that it's as he puts it hostile to
but also coming out of
a culture of education pedagogy right
and also traditions that are by that
time established of philosophy and so
it's in some respect an outlier but it's
not a complete
outlier it's got its own sort of like
backstory development
that takes place but nobody's quite you
know
sure uh exactly you know who counts
in that one of the other key things that
comes up in chapter two is this question
well is cynicism philosophy and
if it is is what kind of philosophy are
we talking about clearly it's a very
practical orientation towards things
does it count as a philosophy in the
same way that stoicism which in some
respects traces
itself back to cynicism or epicureanism
or aristotelianism or platonism
call themselves philosophy right that's
that's a good question to ask
some of the really important themes that
he also
identifies in chapters um
two and three well there's there's
titles or chapter
headings that that kind of give this to
you
fearless speech so for the ancient
cynics
parasia which we i kind of like that
translation fearless speech
um which he's getting from from foucault
uh typically we say like freedom of
speech or frankness of speech but
fear you know fearless speech is is good
as well what does that mean what
what does that count as why are they
engaged in it that's one of the key
questions
[Music]
impoverishment going around with a
minimum
of possessions the cynic
costume or outfit or uniform was a staff
a cloak and a bag it's often translated
as wallet but it was stuff that you'd
you know carry around
so you could you know imagine people
today who are
living as digital nomads are kind of you
know along the same
sort of lines why why were they
practicing impoverishment is it just
that they dropped out of society because
they couldn't fit in man and they had to
you know
get away from the rat race no it was
it had to do with a diagnosis of what we
human beings actually need
and looking at idealized heroes like
you know for example heracles who goes
around
exhibiting you know goodness to people
taking on toils not being particularly
addicted to pleasures
and and doing important actions
so the cynics at best we're doing stuff
like that
there's a great discussion in here of
the cynic attitude towards the body
which has you know kind of um
and i've used this word several times an
ambivalence to
it right there's this notion that you
shouldn't be like just giving in to the
body and
diogenes himself was known
for doing exercises to toughen the body
at the same time the body and its needs
and wants kind of educates you in
in what you uh can do and so there's you
know bodily acts that the cynics do that
are that are
viewed as shameful but they engage in it
without shame
um there's this theme of defacing the
currency right the third chapter is
called to face the currency
this is a term that got used a lot again
associated with diogenes the cynic who
is supposed to either he or his father
to face the currency
and there's actually some historical
reasons recently in archaeological finds
to think that that may
in fact be true um and and it was
typically interpreted
as getting away from
wrong-headed social conventions and
towards a
more natural human life
aggressive teaching is another
subheading that they use the the
diatribe is
associated with cynics another
genre of of um
literature as well or or it could be
also oral actions
is you know comedy put satire
all of those things fit in with the
cynics poking fun at things
there's a question about sophistication
and
you know are the cynics rejecting
sophistication altogether and the answer
is
you know most of the time yes and then
there's like an
actual subheading about [ __ ] and and
uh
why uh are they doing that well
i'll read a little bit of that that
section
um alan says
uh diogenes did something kind of you
know
unseemly he actually took a dump in the
middle
of uh you know a place where everybody
could see it
and unsurprisingly this caused great
insult
and he says one interpretation of what
the aging is up to here is that he was
authenticating his cynicism
by squatting before an audience so he's
showing everybody you know that
that he's um you know he's not going to
be
be held to their rules and then he's you
know he goes on and he says
having disgraced himself so completely
diogenes had no reason to flatter or
dupe them
his authority his cynic philosophy
relied on the assurance that this act
gave his audience that diogenes was not
bound by any convention
including those rules that govern social
intercourse but then you know
alan points out listen he does this in a
very deliberate
way he's sending a message
he says the problem that diogenes
presents is the fact that he chooses to
act such a way and does so
from a position of sophistication
namely from a position that had up until
that point abided
by shared norms of public content
conduct one way of interpreting this act
then is to understand it is an attack on
cultured refinement a blast
from below so a very interesting
discussion there when we get into the
other chapters
you know one of the things that we see
so the the chapter
following the sort of basic presentation
of cynicism
is the one about idealization and we see
that allen
you know he he rejects um these
idealizations
um or he's at least suspicious of them
like he says venerable cynicisms that
have origins that always remain out of
reach
right and we might be able to trace it
back
quite a ways but he's you know he's
interested in
what he calls cynic co-option and he
you know he points out that that stoics
were doing this
right uh he talks about julian the
apostate or julian the emperor there's a
section here
on epictetus there's a section on
lucian the the the you know
who's influenced to some degree by
cynicism there's a discussion about
this emperor julian and
his views on on cynicism and
you have to you have to kind of say too
when you read julian's
orations it's clear that he's not just
arguing
from like a stoic perspective he's
actually got kind of a platonic
perspective
involved there as well then there's this
great discussion of
how christians were appropriating
cynicism
or rejecting it and you know as he put
puts it you know the the the christian
ascetics
were living out a regime of
self-discipline and abstention from
indulgence that bore extreme
more resemblance to the extreme
courageous destitution of the ancient
cynics so you know there's some ideas
that maybe
some christian movements or figures were
actually cynics one one that actually
gets proposed uh in the in the uh
the uh new testament scholarship is
jesus as a cynic right
and there's um
a good discussion here of of uh
slaughter dykes dyke's
examination of of this um
you know it may have been that there was
some cynic influence but it doesn't seem
to be that strong
then there's a discussion of this guy
simeon the fool
who's sort of a christian diogenes
who we we learn about but you know for
the most part
as alan points out the christians are
not particularly
receptive to the these cynics
and then we get this discussion about um
early modernity right and and
of course he has to talk about rob lay
because rob lay
uh you know not only has diogenes is one
of his characters but if you
i mean if you've ever read roblox some
crazy wild
stuff and it you know there could be
some connection to
cynicism um
and you know one of the things he says
is if roblay employs diogenes as a
subversive character and not simply as a
comedic buffoon
his own self-consciously absurd activity
as a tub shuffling drink-toting writer
carries a more devious message namely
those who think they're engaged in more
serious activities than the barrel
rolling
of a lighthearted satirist are the real
dupes
um he says rouble invites only those
readers prepared to savor him without
hesitation or doubt to drink freely
frankly and boldly from his tub now
filled with wine
he also talks about you know the the
role of the body
and he brings in uh baktin and his
interpretation
of rob lay in his his famous you know
work
on on roble and his world um
and he says you know there there are
some connections
here that we could we could highlight
but um you know you know alan doesn't
entirely buy it
then there's this section early modern
malcontents
and here's where we see that you know
cynicism
um it's taking on other forms
now it's not completely different right
you did have sort of
cynics who were using cynicism as an
excuse for world weariness
and misanthropy and
indulging themselves back in ancient
times that's why julian the apostate
writes his
against the uneducated cynics but
um there's probably more of this you
could say
in in in modern times going on
and so there you know there's some
interesting uh
discussions of this is here
chapter six uh unchained the sun
enlightened philosophers and libertines
is
is really bringing the idea home
and he he talks about
um alan talks about how
at this point in time there's a couple
things going on there's still
this reference to capital c cynicism
but now cynicism has has become you
might say unmoored of those
those uh those origins
and people can be identified as
cynics you know during the enlightenment
so he says
for a final take on the ancient
tradition it's necessary to travel from
the english context of the french
enlightenment where writers like
rousseau dietero
and sod were lured once and more once
more in their own idiosyncratic ways by
the attractions of cynic philosophy and
i think
that's right i think that's a good way
to put it each of them has a
project that is their own
i mean you know assad's definitely his
own and rousseau's too
and they're drawing on cynicism to some
degree but they're they're
taking what they want from it and then
leaving out
other parts so you know where where are
the connections right he says
the enlightenment philosopher's sympathy
for the cynic
could be that you know ideas like
freedom from prejudice separation of
morality from
religious constraints cosmopolitanism
the autonomy of the individual all of
these you could get
from cynicism but they're being used in
different ways and um
allen actually says as slodrick argues
modern cynicism can be viewed as the
distant ancestor
of enlightenment critique it can be
understood as the final melancholic
resting place of an
exhausted critical consciousness that
has consumed itself and he's going to
pick that up a little bit
later on
what else do we have going on so in
chapter 7
we have all these different attitudes
towards
towards cynicism and he talks about this
worry that modern people have
of things you know falling apart you
know you can call it nihilism you can
call it cynicism
you can call it the lonely
crowd you know to echo reeseman right
the individual who's atomized from
everybody else
there's all different you know ways of
framing this and you know we'll just
give a few others right collective
apathy is is a form of cynicism
uh the problem with contemporary cynics
is they lack a political imagination
and we could go on and on and on so
here's a good line here
cynicism is said to be the product of a
dangerous self-denying social
socially destructive lack of faith a
dogmatic unthinking rejection of all
efforts to social betterment
it's the condition of those who operate
on the blanket assumption individuals
and institutions are driven
before l by a self-serving impulse an
inbolt built an insatiable greed
and therefore cannot be trusted and so
there's all these different vantage
points from which people criticize
cynicism
some of them are conservative some of
them
are coming from the radical left you
know
marxists don't like cynics for example
some of them are coming from all sorts
of other places you know religious
people are worried about it
there's also a discussion in here and
i'm going to talk about this a little
bit more of late
soviet cynicism which is quite
interesting
as well and one of the things that gets
talked about
in the uh uh last part of this chapter
is a slow radix critique in critique of
cynical reason
right and then whether cynicism has any
insurrectional
um uh what does he call it potential can
can cynicism
you know through intensification
can that actually lead to something new
and then finally there's a discussion in
here of
two other things nietzsche nihilism and
half-assed cynics
nietzsche's you know in you could say
connection with cynicism or
attitudes towards it and then finally
slaughter dick and the code
of [ __ ] right um where cynicism
modern cynicism
is is viewed as problematic but as
something that we can't really escape
the last
part um he begins this last one by
saying
as a result of recent scholarly interest
in the phenomenon of cynicism there's a
growing list of so-called inheritors
of cynic philosophy so these range from
comedians and satirists to tricksters
street artists
political activists we might also add
you know other people as well and the
question here is
can cynicism really do anything or is it
just sort of a
a response an active response but
ultimately an
impotent response to the conditions of
modernity is there really going to be
any sort of
legitimate use in the present of of
cynicism and so you know he talks about
the internet
he also says it's still worth taking up
slower dick's invitation to imagine a
return diogenes climbing out of his
athenian tub
but he says would this really make any
difference
would this really do anything the cynic
would be understood the cynic would be
co-opted and he says should today's
cynic manage to avoid
pathologist pathologization or arrest
for indecency
his or her embodied practices would be
perceived as just another lifestyle
choice
or political statement another
exhibitionist operating within the
boundaries of liberal
acceptability and i think he's pretty
much right so he says
this is sort of the conclusion of of the
work any revival of cynic philosophy is
going to face a number of challenges
and cannot be modeled on ancient
cynicism without considerable
tactical adjustment and then he tries to
you know examine well what would that
actually look like and he's giving you
you know a few ideas there i'm not going
to ruin the book for you by telling you
what all of them are
so those are some of the key ideas that
are being
brought out and put on the table and
again in a very
uh readable way and which is going to be
quite thought provoking
if you do in fact get your hands on this
book
as i think you can probably tell at this
point i'm
a big fan of this book and i'm looking
forward to reading other things by
alan this is really
well thought out well written and
i the first good thing that i want to
point out is
alan has clearly you know gone through
the literature both of ancient cynicism
and of the other
figures that he's bringing up and the
contemporary you know he mentions the
last three decades being very important
in terms of uh cynicism
itself and and academic research on it
and so he's
he's assimilating all of that he's
giving you
you know as far from what i can tell you
know
with some conversancy with the
contemporary literature and all these
other people that he's talking about
he's giving you the best parts he's
giving you the parts that you you need
in this short book he's not doing an
awful lot of
quote blocks or anything he puts it into
his own words
but he's directing you at the right
targets
so this is a really great assimilative
interpretation of the classic literature
and of the scholarship of the last three
decades
there's a great focus on the essential
aspects of
cynic philosophy in its ancient form in
in this idealized
you know maybe kind of platinized form
uh
or christianized form and then you know
what counts as cynicism as we
we move into modernity and the term kind
of breaks up into
to different pictures and gets
transformed
um i think that he does an
excellent job taking cynicism
and its representatives and its key
aspects
and in in placing them into its context
and what i mean by that is
in the different historical and cultural
frameworks
uh allen explains what cynicism means
and what it looks like
in this framework in relation to this
author in relation to this
set of preoccupations or questions or
or problems um there
there are some you know it's it's not a
book that has a
easy solution given at the end
it's also not doing the sort of well
it's all very problematic and you can do
whatever you want with it instead what i
see is alan really grappling with
what it would mean to be a cynic in any
real
sense in in a way that's connected to
classical cynicism and not just being
you know kind of a sourpuss
in the uh modern world you know marked
by
late capitalism and by all these other
developments that have been going on
which which make it easy for
cynicism to be co-opted i see some
really
deep well thought out considerations of
the possibilities for late modern
cynics and i also want to really
highlight
i'm i think it's really cool that
he doesn't just look at
you know the figures that he might
easily
look at but he also discusses
what happened in the soviet union i
think that that's actually quite
quite relevant and it could be
applicable to
other contexts as well there's a kind of
cynicism
that emerges um
from that that yeah here we go late
soviet cynicism he says
for one notable departure from the
blanket assumption that cynicism
cynicism has no positive role to play in
social transformation
it's worth turning to this study of the
last soviet generation in which
alexi yurcock
unpacks what he calls the cynical reason
of late socialism
and so i think this is actually quite
quite interesting
here so he gives you a summary of how
laughter humor and a certain attitude
towards things could uh come about
within that that framework and we know
that part of what led to the
fall of the soviet union and you know
warsaw pact and all of this this
associated stuff it wasn't just like
being exhausted economically or
militarily there was
a bankruptcy that got to be shown
about the the culture itself
and and it left some significant vacuums
in its wake as i know from my eastern
european
friends and colleagues who have talked
about this quite a bit so i think that's
that's an
important thing to discuss and
um it's you know it's a i'll just say
this to you about the book now this
is kind of a matter of um
you could say design right
it's nice how it fits in your hand so
it's a good it's an easy book to
to look through to read it's really well
laid out
it's a very attractive book i would say
so those are the things that i think are
particularly good but but i also say
there's a like in you know a inherent
goodness that runs through the whole
thing
and it's well worth getting
with each work that i review i do talk
about problematic aspects of the work
and
in some cases you know as the reviewer
i'm highlighting things that are
serious problems with with a book in
this case it's really just a matter of
personal preferences i would say
with perhaps one exception
you know the things that i have to say
here might be viewed less
as critiques and more as quibbles but
i'll put them out there
anyway because you may find them
interesting so you know
i'm i'm not a fan with the design thing
and i know this is more mit
than alan himself of these
page things like this it's sort of like
uh
you know when you have blog entries and
they do this big block out thing or they
do that in magazine stuff
i don't think that belongs in books
i don't find that particularly helpful
you know i can find the passages in
there
and i don't think it's i don't think
it's adding any value to do that you
know this is just a page that that's
that's wasted and it's kind of like it
interrupts your
your reading again total quibble right
um so that that's one thing i i'm not
sure that i
buy the criticisms
of post-modernism that are being invoked
in the second to last
chapter and this is actually
interestingly
in a section called radical left
grievances
so here's what alan says um
cynicism can perhaps be forgiven for its
stupidity so long as it yields to
remedy right uh less forgivable for some
are the fashionable cynicisms of
left postmodern theory and he's got left
in
quotes there which are blamed for
inviting skepticism before all truth
claims and doubt before our ability to
submit the
world about us to the dictates and
progressive impulses of reason
in this context cynicism becomes a
synonym for postmodernism
construed as a quote the based cultural
form a monstrous hybrid aesthetic a
decadent self-indulgent apoliticism and
an elitist ironical nihilism
post-modernism is here characterized as
fundamentally
cynical though not in quote cynically
suffering like
slownerdic's melancholic victim of
enlightenment but cynically destructive
the perpetrator of a sinister assault on
cognitive
aesthetic and moral certainties
and then you know he goes on and he says
i would argue
those railing against this specific type
of cynicism tend to misunderstand its
nature
misread its intent and vastly
overestimate its reach and influence and
i think he's right about that
but he says and yet such critics of
postmodern theory will find a
sympathetic
audience he's not coming straight out
and saying listen this this
take on post-modernism is [ __ ] which
i think he should have said
um because clearly he does think it's
[ __ ]
he's just not being completely uh clear
with that
and and you know i think this is this is
important uh interestingly like i
mentioned though this is not the
right-wingers talking about you know
post-modern marxism or whatever all you
know weird
conglomerates they're gonna they're
gonna bring up who knows what it'll be
uh a year from now that'll be the the
latest boogie man but
so again a a quibble more than an actual
criticism
um early in the work there's an
assertion
that i don't i don't know if i really
buy
that um the philosophical status of
cynicism its place within the canon
is difficult to establish given that it
had no fixed dogmata and seems to have
operated without a defined end or
philosophical goal
otherwise known as a telos
you know this really depends on what
works we're going to take
as probably you know definitive
um i think this depends on the choices
that we we make i i will say this
in the scholarship on cynicism there is
a tendency
you know in the last 30 years to to
adopt that sort of
point of view i'm just not convinced of
it and
you know me maybe allen has got it right
and maybe i'm wrong about that but it
does seem to me that if we take
the angenese liertas and you know
antisthenes portrayal and xenophon
symposium
and some of the other things seriously
enough they do have some dogmata they're
just not
there's no like list of principal
doctrines or anything like that
so i don't know about that the other
thing i'll mention too
is there is this tendency
in uh modern scholarship on the cynics
to say
that um the the genealogy of the cynics
is actually just a made-up thing later
on
that you know it's sort of like looking
back and
antisthenes really wasn't a cynic he may
not have taught diogenes at all
um the stoics you know create this this
timeline and genealogy to justify their
own stuff i just you know same thing too
with like rejecting
lucian's dialogue as not being
genuinely by lucian because he gives you
know he lets the cynic argue
against him and and win the argument i
don't know that i
buy these things i can't say that i'm
like a you know
campaign destinies guy or something like
that
but i i think that it is a problem
and you know the fact that antisthenes
doesn't get brought up
in the work until the fourth chapter
i see that as i see that as not a weak
point but an
interpretive choice that i don't i don't
share so again
i don't actually have any big criticisms
of the work these are just things that
people might find
interesting uh if if they're into
cynicism
so on the whole too
these are greatly outweighed by the good
points of the work
all right to sum up um if you want to
know about
ancient cynicism and its possibilities
for
applicability within the present you
want to get this book
really well written and
you know it's scholarly but also
readable by the
ordinary person there is a lot to learn
if you if you haven't read much about
the cynics or some of the other
figures who are being mentioned you're
going to learn quite a lot
from getting this book even if you are
somebody
who encountered the cynics you know
decades ago
and has been thinking about them and
teaching about them you can
benefit from as i have from reading this
book so
anscar allen cynicism i you know
without any qualifications recommend it
you